Tom Hanks and Rita Wilson reveal what
it's like to work together as a married
couple who kind of wears the pants it's
both Tom and Rita are back on as
producers for My Big Fat Greek Wedding
to hitting theaters March 25th who says
a woman has to be mine you all our lives
on Tuesday at the film's premiere in New
York City the couple opened up to et
about why they keep their marriage and
work life separate it's it's our lives
day in and day out so we really don't
talk about it much what do we come up in
their stuff to do but we don't we don't
that would just be so boring and they'd
have to come home and talk about it at
dinner as well we walk away from I walk
away I run away from my real
responsibilities as a aside from
producing and acting the 59 year old has
been busy with her new album she's
getting ready to head out on tour and
her hubby said he plans to join her on
the road hop on and off that bus I'm not
gonna miss out on the rock and roll tour
bus experience I'm already I got a lava
lamp already to plug in I got some
blacklight posters our drug of choice is
chocolate